[Captions by Y Translator]
Kinetic sand is
a weird combination
of fine grit colored sand
and a rubberized polymer.
We wanted to see what happens
if you heat it up
in a variety of ways.
Can you burn it?
Can you melt it?
What happens if you
put it in a microwave?
[Music]
We've done some fun experiments
with kinetic sand in the past
including casting metal into it
in a few different ways.
And now we want to see
what happens if we apply
heat really directly.
We've got five different methods
that we're gonna use to apply
heat to our kinetic sand
and see what it does.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got some colors
of kinetic sand,
and we're going to try applying
heat to them in a few different ways.
We're gonna try
our backyard foundry,
we'll try our arc furnace,
we'll see what happens
if you boil kinetic sand,
microwave kinetic sand
and hit it with a blowtorch.
First off, let's take some sand,
put in a crucible,
and get it going in our backyard foundry.
Will the sand burn?
Will the sand actually melt?
Can we turn this into glass?
Let's find out.
[Music]
Sand in our crucible is,
I think it's actually
on fire now.
Fair bit of flame coming up out
of the crucible at this point.
It's, it's kind of fun
cause it's got
like swirling smoke.
Well, then like the fire
gets into two.
We've almost got
a little bit of fire tornado
coming up out of here.
Okay, we've got a couple
of multicolored sea creatures
here just sitting
on a piece of fire brick.
We're gonna see what happens
if we go for a really
direct approach with our heat.
We're gonna just hit him
with a blowtorch and see
what happens to him.
We've got a blowtorch
and our little sand creatures.
Wow!
As soon as the heat
gets on that,
it's like the pink
changes to purple.
And it actually goes
away a little bit
when it cools down.
So once we've got gray,
I don't think there's
any coming back from that.
I think it's pretty
much ruined at that point.
Burned all the color
and the polymer out of it.
Let's keep this going.
[Music]
Oh, That arm is gone,
that arm is gone.
Starfish are supposed
to be able to regrow arms,
but this might be
too much for it.
[Music]
So here's the sand
that got the most heat
on it and it's just
completely a powder.
Over here some sand,
they get burned, but it's
also still cohesive.
It's staying together
a little bit.
Then in the very middle,
there's the part
that still have their color.
So the color goes first and then
the ability to hold together,
and then it's just powder.
[Music]
All right.
So we've got a glowing
orange crucible
full of what appears to just be
really hot sand at the moment.
Don't think we got much
more results from that
although, a little bit on the side,
looks like maybe it vitrified.
We've melted glass
in this same crucible before,
so it's hard to know what
exactly it is we're looking at.
See if we can pour
some of this out.
[Music]
Oh, that's cool,
glowing orange glass powder.
[Music]
Some glass with embedded
sand right here,
some very fine-grain sand too,
much more so
than playground sand
or something like that.
[Music]
Yi-hi-hi, It works just right.
This is cool.
So I'm just dripping
water onto our sand
and our sand is extremely hot.
So as the water gets poured in,
it seeps down past the sand,
but then it keeps getting
heated up and boiling away.
So it's just bubbling
underneath the super hot sand.
Overall though, I would say there is
like none of the polymer left.
This is just sand at this point.
I'm gonna take
our little castle mould
and fill it with some
of our blue and green sand
and then we're going
to try putting it in a microwave,
and see if that does anything to it.
[Music]
Still put a little longer.
The plate that this is sitting
on is now hot enough
that it's uncomfortable to touch
but the sand itself...
[Music]
Not tasting, I'm just feeling it
on something more sensitive.
It's warm.
It's not hot.
Really doesn't seem
to heat up much
like it's definitely
much warm on the bottom.
I think most of the heat
that it's experiencing,
is coming up through the plate
at the bottom and into the sand,
but the microwave
doesn't seem to affect
the sand very much at all.
Let's go for broke.
Just gonna put it in
for three, four more minutes.
[Music]
Once again,
the bottom is fairly warm,
but that is mostly
from the plate,
which is very hot.
And the top of a sand
is just kind of normal.
I've got a small pot
of boiling water
and now let's see what happens
if we boil a little sand castle.
[Music]
Here it goes.
Don't see a lot going on
with our sand that's
in our boiling water either.
It may have begun
to puddle just a little bit lose
a tiny bit of definition,
but you can see
that a lot of the definition is
actually still there.
All the little tiny stair steps,
that little crenellations
on the top of the towers are
still quite visible.
It appears that on the inside,
the water hasn't made it through.
So this stuff I think is
kind of waterproof.
Outside is getting boiled
but inside is not
really changing much.
Just let it run
for a few more minutes.
You have started
to see a result.
During enough time, in the water.
I did add some more water this
had boiled quite low.
[Music]
Let's pour off the water
and see how this stuff is.
[Music]
The water is slightly
tinted green.
[Music]
Little hard to tell,
but it doesn't feel
like it's acting the same.
[Music]
This is acting a lot more
like wet sand,
and a lot less like kinetic sand.
I may have ruined it.
Let's do a side
by side comparison.
Here's our kinetic sand unheated,
and our boiled kinetic sand.
[Music]
Not even the same color
anymore, but close.
This is yellower.
So we definitely had to boil it
for a little while
before we had an effect.
At first,
It didn't seem to change much
but after about 10 minutes,
it seems to have completely
ruined the effect.
We've tried some things
that heat it up
our sand a fair amount,
but now we're going to try when
that heats it up a lot more.
We're going to use
our arc furnace
and see what happens.
Castle being made
of not just built on sand
but literally being made of sand
has collapsed a little bit
into our heart furnace.
That's okay.
[Music]
That right there is melted sand.
So it very quickly ruins
the effect of the kinetic sand
and see like,
look at this digging down
into it still burns,
still burns.
So that got hot enough to ruin
our kinetic sand quickly
and our one little spot
where we had all
of our heat concentrated,
we got it to melt and turn it
into a crude form of glass.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next
and if you hit this bomb
in the middle,
you'll be subscribed to our channel.
and that way
you'll never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.